[Music]
so for our daily cancellation today we
have an onion of stupid with layers that
we must peel our way through one by one
we start with a priest by the name of
thomas reese who a few days ago shared
an article from religion news titled
why our preferred pronouns for god
should be they
now if you know anything about these
matters you've already guessed that
reese is a jesuit he's also an author
with a large social media following the
article in question was written by a guy
named mark silk who is according to his
bio
the professor and director of greenberg
center for the study of religion in
public life at trinity college as well
as an editor for religion news
now he begins his screed writing
he says quote writing last week in the
new york times linguistic professor john
mcquarter waxed enthusiastic about the
advent of they as our all-purpose third
person singular pronoun
now we'll get back to the blasphemy in
the first article in just a moment but i
want to take a step to the side here to
read a few lines from that new york
times article first as it apparently
inspired the other one that piece is
titled gender pronouns are changing it's
exhilarating
and this alleged linguistic professor
writes
the other day i had occasion to use the
pronoun they in the new way referring to
a specific person not your grandfather's
father's singular they with its generic
meaning
a student can hand their paper in early
if they want to
but they as in roberto wants a haircut
and they also want some highlights
i wangled it
wengled
i don't know what that means but it
required a bit of conscious effort
pronouns sit deeply in our cognition
used constantly and bound by habit
it's their turn to use the kite don't
you think
i said thinking consciously about my
sentence in a way that i don't have to
usually
i know some find it wearying why does
language have to change all the time
with all we have to think about but
we're not unique there are times when
the language firmament shifts under
people's feet and they get through it
and then he goes through a number of
examples of times when language has
changed in the past insisting that this
is no different and he wraps it up this
way says
they tell you mountains become sand but
you never get to see it language change
happens faster and you actually get to
get to witness it it's something to
treasure yes you see it is in fact a
great privilege to have a bunch of
people with blue hair and nose piercings
make up new rules of grammar on the spot
and demand that you follow them
it is exhilarating and majestic like
watching mountains become sand
granted some of the people in this group
uh may have the girth of mountains but
the comparison still seems like a
stretch but anyway i'll have more to say
about the you know in response to that
but first let's get back to mark silk
over at religion religion news who in
his article
inspired by this new york times piece
writes quote
in contrast to being humans it has long
been accepted that god is not gendered
at least within the within the main
abrahamic theological tradition a phrase
such as god the father should be treated
as a metaphor and for those concerned
about the embedded misogyny of the
tradition to say nothing of post-binary
folks a deeply problematic one as a
result we have been faced liturgically
as well as theologically with the
imperative of gender-neutral language
which means being obliged to repeat the
word god where a gendered pronoun would
normally be used and to have recourse to
the unattractive neologism god's self
lest god forbid we find ourselves saying
himself
they theirs them and themself or maybe
themselves solves the problem as in
praise god for whom all blessings flow
praise them all creatures here below etc
all right now that we have the whole
picture here confused as it is
a few responses
first on the issue of language evolution
in general we must continue to note that
this pronoun stuff is not a natural
evolution
it's true that language changes over
time
language is fluid in that way
language is a symbol it's a sound meant
to represent something
you could argue that language is
fundamentally arbitrary in that way
we say elephant to talk about elephants
and camels to talk about camels but
things could have worked out so that we
say camels to talk about animals we now
call it elephants and elephants for
camels there's no reason why we had to
use the particular sounds we used to
represent those animals that's just how
it worked out
that's why language can shift and change
over time that's true
now in the times article many examples
are given of past shifts in language
it's argued that what we're experiencing
today is just more of the same
but it's not it's very different
because most changes in language happen
relatively organically
due to a wide combination of influences
people begin to slightly adjust the
verbal symbols they use for certain
things and eventually the official
grammatical rules as written in grammar
textbooks and so forth will change also
but they change descriptively not
proscriptively they are describing and
codifying a change that is already
underway
what's happening with pronouns is not
like this rather it's a top-down change
the grammar rules are being changed
prescriptively
our culture elites have decided for
ideological reasons that we ought to be
using different words and they plan to
berate and scold and punish us until we
comply
this is not a natural evolution of
language this is an intentional
manipulation of language which is a very
different thing so just like what
they're doing with the with the made-up
nonsensical word la tinx
or latinx
nobody in that community uses the word
or likes it yet the cultural elites keep
using it and pushing it and pushing it
hoping that eventually people will
submit and start adopt adopting it in
daily use if and when that day happens
they'll then turn around and say look at
that language evolved
but calling that natural evolution is
like injecting drugs into a lab rat and
calling it natural evolution when it
grows a third ear
now there have been other examples of
this kind of unnatural imposed evolution
of language the times piece mentions a
few like when african-american became
the preferred term in the 90s to
supplant black and then we went back to
black again which was then replaced by
people of color which is considered
politically correct while colored people
is horrifically racist all of that is
arbitrary ludicrous and it's mostly the
result of cultural elites again telling
us what words we should be using
and yet even this isn't as bad as the
pronoun changes because in this case the
verbal symbols to describe a certain
reality are are being changed but with
the pronouns they wish to change the
symbols
and the thing that's being symbolized
the point of making pronouns fluid and
genderless is to give the impression
that people people are fluid and
genderless
they're not just trying to change the
way we describe thing things they're
also trying to change that which is
being described overall you know
language is supposed to convey meaning
language if it changes is supposed to
change in order to make meaning more
clear but in this case language is
changing in order to make our meaning
more obscure that's the difference
and it's pretty big difference
and that brings us to the issue of god's
pronouns
notice how the article refers to our
preferred pronouns for god that's
instructive because the author doesn't
seem concerned with god's preferred
pronouns for himself
on that end if you're an adherent to any
of the abrahamic religions there's no
question about it god prefers to be
referred to as he
that's how his book refers to him
that's what his prophets call him and if
you're a christian you know that the son
of god emphasis on son here
not only called god father but also
was himself a hymn it's true that god
has no biological sex because god
created biological sex he created
biology he transcends male or female
he does we don't
and yet god wants us to understand his
relationship to us as that of a father
to his children do i fully understand
what that means
can i fully comprehend that cosmic
analogy no neither can you but that's
what god has told us and that's what
he's given us
i find it quite telling that according
to some people like the writer of this
article and the priest who shared it we
should respect everybody's preferred
pronouns except for god
for him we can impose our own onto him
we have our preferred pronouns for him
rather than respecting the ones that he
prefers for
himself because that's what all of this
is really about in the end isn't it
it's about putting us at the center and
what we want at the center
rather than subjecting ourselves to any
greater truth
like god or even like
grammar and that's why everyone
associated
with that article they're all
canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends